hi everybody so welcome to a special
presentation filled with lasers and
kittens and the mouth UFOs along with
machine learning and Python programming
of course and I'm glad some kids can
join us too so I'm a PhD candidate at a
North Carolina State University and my
classmate Mario yaha and my advisor dr.
labor were also in this project and the
dr. labor coded the base of the video
game in PI him that Mario yaja made the
various hood improvements and graphical
improvements and I was mainly
responsible for building the artificial
intelligence part just a little warning
so here's the road map of the talk first
I will give you guys a motivation of why
we care about these projects now we
introduce the game mechanics of laser
cut and then comes the important part
when we start building the AIS so we
start with the easy one the imitation AI
which will imitate a human players
behavior we will see how we can
formulate under solve it as a supervised
learning program problem then we'll get
to the more exciting part where we build
our self evolving AI which uses
reinforcement learning and we will see
that it is quite different from
supervisor learning in the end we have a
big finale but I don't want to spoil it
just yet ok so why do we care at all
about doing projects on our video game
well besides the obvious reason that is
cool so video games are actually great
test bed for various machine learning
algorithms they are designed to be
beautiful but also are difficult enough
to give the player a challenge so it is
a great test bed for you to try and
improve your algorithms for example
deepmind from Google I wrote a paper
about trying the reinforcement learning
algorithms on all the various eighth
horror games and now more recently we
know that the alphago was able to beat a
human professional go player
and now thirdly many real-world problems
can be formulated as a sequential
decision making problem similar to a
video game so in a video game you look
at the screen and then you decide which
action you want to take so problems like
self-driving vehicles you see what's in
front of you and then you pick the right
decision to make who are personalized
medicine where you observe the patient's
historical status and then pick the best
treatment for the patient or
counterterrorism or you know that the
terrorism are on the on the run but you
have limited resources from the police
department what's the best strategy to
allocate your resources to catch the
terrorists so all these problems can be
formulated as a sequential decision
making problems and now you can solve
them just like video games so here's the
demo of what the game looks like you are
controlling this cat here and you shoot
lasers at the mouths UFOs and you can
move in eight directions in each
direction you can either take a small
step or a big step a big step allows you
to move faster but you also lose
precision you get points for shooting
the UFOs you lose points for colliding
with them or letting them escape and the
catch is the closer you are to the left
boundary the more points you get for
curing the UFOs so it's a high-risk
high-reward system as mentioned the game
is beauty I game it's a library in
Python and there are a lot of great
tutorials online to teach you how to
make real games but the focus of this
talk will be on the AI portion not the
game making portion and there are three
key functions that are allowed to build
a AI first need to be able to extract
information from the current state of
the game and a secondly you want to map
the information to the desired action
and now you want to be able to pass the
action back to the agent so I'll execute
it in the video game the third under the
the first under the third steps are
relatively straightforward they come
to knowing the correct syntax which you
can learn from the tutorials and we are
going to focus on the second part which
is going to be the brain of the AI so
let's start with imitation learning and
then in this part the AI is going to try
to imitate a human players behavior so
the data is generated by the human
player and we can formulate as a
supervised learning program problem
where the the predictors will be the
coordinates of each object on the screen
the lasers the small UFOs the big UFOs
the cat etc and then the response which
is the correct answer is the action that
the human player took so this will be
the screen shot and we have these
various objects we will just extract
their coordinates and use them as the
features or predictors and try to let
the agent imitate a human's behavior but
the catch is not everything is on the
screen so maybe you cue some UFOs so
there's only one UFO on the screen but
maybe when you miss there'll be 2 or 3
or 4 UFOs on the screen and at some
times there's one laser on the screen
sometimes they are three leaders on the
screen so there are a lot of missing
values and the these missing models are
a little bit special different from
normal missing values in which case the
missing values exist but we just feel to
measure them so you can use the various
methods to impute these missing values
but here if the third and the fourth
Mouse are missing it's not because we
couldn't measure them it's because they
are not there so it doesn't make sense
to impute them this is called a
structural missingness so how can we
handle this a structural missing this
pattern we will build something called a
hierarchical random forest model so
first we look at the data and then we
divide the data into different
categories based on the missing value
patterns so maybe category 1 a
no mouse no laser just a cat category
two will be one laser no Mouse just a
cat and category 3 would be 1 laser one
mouse and so on so after we divided the
data into different categories within
each category there is no missing value
anymore because they all have the equal
number of inputs and after dividing data
into different sub categories we build a
separate model for each category and we
don't have the missing value problem and
here you can use your favorite
classifier we use the random forest but
you can also use support vector machine
or artificial neural networks and now in
Python you can just use the succulent
library where it gives you a huge
variety of machine learning algorithms
so we are ready to see how the AI does
an ad hoc on the top will be the human
employee and on the bottom is the
employee from a hierarchical random
forest ai and it's important to note
that this is the test data so this data
these data are not part of the training
and this is a test data and so here the
AI is trying to predict what I would
have done in this scenario and on the
top is that I replay the game using the
same
seed basically to make a comparison so
not too bad and this AI is actually only
using 2 hours of gameplay so actually
with more data you can do on even better
but I was going in saying from playing
hours of laser cut so I just had to stop
there
all right so from Terminator to Skynet
what you just saw imitation learning AI
is a in essence deterministic he's
trying to imitate the humans on behavior
so it's deterministic and you cannot
evolve on its own but a chewy I should
be able to learn and evolve on its own
with
a teacher you should be able to get
smarter and smarter and eventually
surpass human intelligence and hopefully
there's to our friends at that point so
in other words we want to move from
Terminator to Skynet and we'll see how
we can actually build a Skynet to do
that we use a different algorithm is
called a reinforcement learning so here
you have a agent which is the learner
and a decision maker it will observe the
current state of the of the environment
which is what in the agent interacts
with it observes the current state and
it will try to pick an action and that
in turn
the action is going to influence the
environment and make it move to the next
state the environment will also provide
the agent of feedback scudder reward it
quantifies the desirability and then a
policy is a map from the observed state
to the action and the policy itself can
deposit can evolve over time so
typically the agent starts from knowing
nothing so it would be a random
completely random policy a random walk
policy and over time you want to be able
to use the reward as the feedback to let
the policy converge to an optimal policy
so this concept actually comes from
animal psychology so if you train dogs
when he does the right move you give a
treat and the same thing for humans so
the first time you eat ice cream you
really like it so in the future you know
that eating ice cream is the correct
actions you want to do the action more
or if you accidentally eat a chili
pepper and they burn your lips off next
time you know you want to avoid chili
peppers so the concept comes from human
psychology and our agent is going to
explore by draw an arrow and try to
learn the optimum policy now this is
different from supervised learning in
supervised learning instead of a reward
signal you get a correct label so you
know what the right answer should be but
our reward is a slightly different it
could be inactive or it could be
positive
and it can be continuous so even Y is
positive you don't know for sure if it
means that your action is correct
because maybe there's a different action
will give you a bigger reward and that
will be the better action to take and
the other thing is the reward can be
delayed so the right action might give
you a negative immediate might give you
a positive immediate reward but in the
long run it might give you a negative
reward
so for example you're like eating ice
cream so eating every ice cream will
give you a positive reward or you keep
eating it and a couple hours later you
get stomachache so that's a big negative
reward so the actions that you overeat
ice cream is actually incorrect but you
wouldn't find out immediately so the
reward is a is a weaker signal than the
correct labels and that's why
reinforcement learning is also called a
semi supervisor learning so we can look
at these concepts in laser-cut the agent
is going to be that hat or the AI that
controls the cut and then everything
surrounded is the environment which the
cat is going to interact with and then
the cat will make take an action and
then the environment will move to the
next state and here we can see as I
mentioned the reward can be delayed
because for the cat moves to this
position it is the correct action but
the laser hasn't reached to the mouse
yet so the immediate reward of this
action is actually zero and whether when
a laser accuses the mouse and you get a
positive reward the cat might be doing
something completely irrelevant so the
tricky thing is how do we assign the
correct actions the credits the other
challenge is the sparsity of rewards the
game actually runs at a 50 frame rates
per second so you have 50 states per
second and you only get a reward signal
in a very small portion proportion of
the states so it's a very sparse and
weak signal and the third thing is we
want to be able to handle the
exploration versus exploitation
trade-off as I mentioned if you want to
find out good policies you have
explore but once you have some good good
candidate policies do you just use the
currently beste policy to get as many
rewards as possible or do you keep
exploring and potentially again really
inactive rewards it's like you you want
to try different restaurants do you go
to your favorite restaurant and order
your favorite dishes or do you try our
new restaurant which could become your
new favorite or it could be completely
disastrous and that usually there are
just too many scenarios that could be
too many restaurants and too many dishes
for you to try exhaustively so how do
you decide that the current policy is
good enough so these tricky things will
be answered by the subsequent slides now
as I mentioned the short-term reward
could be misleading if we just focus on
a short-term reward in the long run you
might get into really bad situations so
instead of looking at a reward we want
to look at something more meaningful
it's called the value of a state so
basically the value of a state is the
expected cumulative long-term reward
from following a certain policy starting
from the current state it's going to be
the sum where RT is the immediate reward
plus a discount factor times the reward
of the next state plus a discount factor
squared times the reward of the next
next state and so on so it's a long-term
cumulative reward but we need this a and
this discount factor is going to
determine how much weight you put into
future rewards compared to the more
recent rewards if gamma is close to 1
then you care more about the future
rewards if gamma is 0 then the value of
a state reduces to the immediate reward
so gamma is the trade-off between long
term and the short term rewards and if
we look at this summation we can leave
the immediate reward here and we can
group the remaining terms over here and
we'll pull our gamma and now we find out
that within the bracket is actually the
expression
of the value of the next state and it is
actually quite intuitive this is saying
the value of the current state is equal
to the immediate reward plus a discount
factor times the value of the next state
so we care about the immediate reward or
we also care about the how promising the
future state is so this equation in
theory should hold but in practice when
these are all estimates the equation is
not going to hold and actually the right
hand side will carry more information
than the left hand side because the
immediate reward is observed so the
right hand side carries more information
and that will actually give us the
updating algorithm we start by randomly
initializing the values we had as T and
we had as T plus 1 and then because the
right hand side carries more information
we let the current estimate take a small
step towards the right hand side so this
is a convex combination of the current
left-hand side under the right hand side
and this carries more information we
take a small step towards the right hand
side and alpha is the learning rate you
might ask why don't we just let alpha
equal to 1 and just use the right hand
side to completely replace left hand
side because here the RT is actually the
expected reward and the in fact is the
reward itself can be our random variable
so if we just let alpha be too big
you're asked miss can just move our
shift around if the reward is random but
just knowing the value of a state might
not be enough because maybe you know
that the some state has a really high
value but if you don't know how the game
works if you don't know the mechanics of
the game you don't know which action
you're supposed to take here we know
because we we wrote the game but if you
face a new problem even though you know
a state is desirable if you don't know
how to get there
that is pointless in terms of how to
choose your actions which is why we just
make a small modification instead of
looking at the value of a state
look at the value of a state action pair
so Q as T 18 which is the value of a
state action pair is the expected
accumulative long-term reward from
executing action 80 at st and following
pi afterwards so the only difference
here is that we this denotes the value
of executing action 80 and then suppose
we know that the Q function of an
optimal policy Q star is known then it
is straightforward to choose the best
action we just choose the action that
gives us the maximum expected a long
term reward so if Q star is known
choosing the action you straight forward
is the Maximizer now recall the equation
from before it's actually called a
bellman equation the long term reward of
current state is equal to an immediate
reward plus discount factor times the
long term reward of the next state and
very similarly the q function has a
similar equation we have the long term
reward under optimum policy of a state
action pair equal to the immediate
reward plus discount factor times the
maximum of the Q value of the next state
here we have this maximum because we
know the best action is the Maximizer so
that optimum policy is going to follow
this equation and a similar to before we
can use this equation to give have the
update algorithm so although these
equations maybe take some time to digest
we can see that a programming
programming wise it is almost trivial so
that's the good part
and then I going back to the exploration
versus exploitation power a policy when
you want to explore usually the typical
path that you choose is called the
Absalon greedy policy when you have a
small probability to explore random
action and you have a large probability
to pick the current
best action and then you can decide how
how you can TR tune the probability
parameter to decide how much you want to
explore and how much you want to exploit
in essence this algorithm actually
allows you to get the optimum policy no
matter what exploration paths you choose
so you can just use random walk policy
but sometimes there will be stability
issues and the in the laser-cut the
actual algorithm implemented is called a
busy learning it's a variation of the
cue learning algorithm because my brain
usually is just done upon hearing the
word Bayesian so we won't go into that
today other one that happened to you in
this short talk but if you're curious
and very high level we are still going
to use the right hand side to update the
left hand side by instead of updating
the point estimate we put a prior
distribution on the left hand side and
we use the right hand side as a sample
to update the posterior distribution but
you might recall so all this sounds
really good but notice that they are
dealing with a the state is an input so
what happens if the states are
continuous like in a video game it's
continuous and they're just so many
states how do you find how can you
possibly find the Q values of each state
action pair they are simply too many
states and if it's truly continuous
there are infinitely many states so we
have to somehow our handle the
continuous States or large states
problem and the one strategy is to use a
parametric function approximation right
instead of assigning a Q value assigning
a Q value to every state action pair you
use a parametric function to approximate
the state it can be deep learning or
splines or radial basis functions or the
other way which is the more
straightforward way is a color
segmentation we simply discretize the
continuous States and then make them
into discrete States
examples include tile coding or nearest
neighbors and
so if you look at a typical
reinforcement learning problem it's got
a mountain car when you try to drive the
car to the goal position but you had to
back away a little bit and again gain
enough momentum to drive all the way to
the right and so this is a continuous
state and we can simply lay out a bunch
of grids on top of the state and now we
can use this grid to track the
approximate position of the mountain car
and then for each small grid we can
assign it a Q value for each action so
in this way we return our continuous
States into discrete States and we can
do everything just like before now the
tricky thing about laser cut is here we
wanted to track one car the mountain car
but in laser cat we have a cat a big UFO
small UFO and the lasers who have so
many objects to track and if we if we
try to build grids for each object and
now it has us to consider the
interactions of them to truly discretize
the States and I will simply be to money
on States so we have to improvise a
little bit and do something we can call
it the mobile how cooling so instead of
laying a stationary grid for each object
and try to track them all and I consider
the interactions we notice that the we
can play this game greedily by just
letting the cat try to shoot the first
Mouse and then we can simply build a
grid which centers at the mouse and the
moves with the mouse so the grid is no
longer stationary it moves with the
mouse and it tracks the relative
position of the cat with respect to the
mouse so now we only need the one grid
to solve this problem I guess a small
detail is that so how big should this
grid be this good actually needs to be
four times the screen size not just one
screen size because the cat can be in
all four quadrants I with respect to the
mouse so like worst case can be the
mountain or left corner kinds on the
right corner where mass is not a top
left corner cat is on the bottom right
corner so we need
good to be four times the screen size
and now you can just do like integer
division with something to just run down
and get approximate coordinates of the
cat and now you can label them and then
treat them as discrete states so now we
know how to update the Q values and we
know how to turn laser cut into a
discrete a reinforcement learning
problem and that's actually all we need
to know to build our self-evolving a
[Music]
don't tell PETA okay so let's do a small
recap and here we start with the
motivation behind a projects of video
games as I said life is a game many
real-life problems can be formulated as
a sequential decision making problem and
we can solve them as a video games and
now we learn how to build imitation
learning AI we were we can use the
coordinates or just various features you
can construct from the current state of
the game as features and then the human
player action as the correct answer and
we can do the predictive model and we
use the hierarchical model structure to
handle the missing data problem and now
we learn how to build a self evolving AI
is the reinforcement learning algorithm
allows the AI to explore and learn the
best policy by trial and error and we
learned that value functions are the
long-term cumulative reward of a state
and it is more informative compared to
the immediate reward and if you don't
know the mechanics of the game you can
use Q learning instead of estimating the
value function to know what the best
action should be without knowing the
mechanics of the game and then lastly we
see how we can use segmentation method
to turn the continuous state into a
discrete discrete States and I'd like to
point out that the Devils are always in
the details
so although the algorithms imperative is
straightforward usually they are just a
huge variety of algorithms and then some
of them work in your case some of them
don't and when it don't work sometimes
you can just be because you missed a one
hyper parameter or because the problem
is in Italy not possible for the
algorithm so finding out what works and
what doesn't work is the most painful
and the hardest part and not before I
take questions I like to share my
contact information so you can get this
a video game laser cat on the website of
my research group for just $12.99 for
them yeah actually you can you can play
it for free
here's mine and here's my email and I'll
take questions right please thank you
for that that was awesome presentations
I was curious about the policy in terms
of since the self-learning
a I actually iterates to get to the
optimal policy is there any
investigation of what was actually
derived at the end like is there a
feedback loop for a human then to
analyze that policy that was optimized
and gained some new insight into how to
play the game better themselves yes
so could you call yes so you you can see
how the AI works so see see that ah so
are recorded to the the Q value is a
function of the state and the action and
the state itself are and that if the
states are continuous we can approximate
this Q value with a parametric function
so it can be deep learning or just in
the simple case we can consider it to be
a linear approximation so see the the Q
function is a linear linear combination
of the coordinates of the objects and
then as the AI place is going to try to
find out what the correct parameters in
our linear combinations are so you will
know that given given a current
coordinates of all the objects what are
what the values correspond to which
action and once you know what the Q
values are you know what a best action
will be so think of the learning process
as learning the correct parameters for
the estimates of the optimum q value so
in essence you can in the end you can
see what the correct parameters will be
what is a video game well what is a
video game a video game is a sequential
decision making problem which is which
is the most important problem in the
world and you can't grow up and become a
statistician as the environment becomes
more and more complex how well does does
this hold you know if you had more
actions a 3d environment so it's the
curse of dimensionality right which is a
present in all the video games so
usually when the environment is more
complicated the simple methods won't
work like even how cooling could just be
insufficient or your environment is is
huge so it which is why recently deep
learning is gaining a lot of popularity
when they will just use a deep neural
network to do the function approximation
so here we are to cheating a little bit
by extracting the coordinates of the
objects but you can imagine a real life
we can't extract the coordinates we can
only observe the screen so now the the
2d image becomes the input but you can
use a neural network to use that input
like a convolution on your network and
you can use the image itself as the
input to future Q function but of course
that still relies on more complicated
algorithm and the more computing power
so I know you said you didn't want to
talk about it but why be Bayesian so the
basic algorithm like the key difference
between the BC and the classical Q funky
learning is that in the classical Q
learning usually the exploration policy
is absent greedy as I mentioned with a
high probability you choose the current
best action with a small probability you
randomly explore all the unknown actions
but a beast and Q learning the nice
thing about it is that it's doing our
more educated exploration because you'll
be updating the distributions of the Q
functions and now when you pick the
action you're actually sampling from the
distributions so say if an action hasn't
been explored before is prior
distribution has a high variance so when
you sample it there's a high probability
that it becomes the largest value and
you can sample
you get to explore it and then there are
several competing actions they maybe
have very similar distributions but
their distributions will give you higher
means and the worst actions so you end
up exploring those actions more but in
short in B's and Q learning you end up
exploring the more competitive the
several top candidates more often than
the remaining actions we are seeing
classical Q learning you explore all the
actions randomly no as well as the keep
our a we don't want to use a prior
knowledge we don't want to use domain
knowledge we want to let the AF figure
itself so in the biz and kerning we put
a non informative prior to other Q
values so it can be a normal
distribution with a very very large
variance or you can just be a uniform
distribution does that actually test or
sub here maximum likelihood because I
guess like when I think of Bayesian
methods I think it's like you know it
allows you to more efficiently learn
something about your data when you have
some you know you have good prior
knowledge basically mm-hmm but as I
mentioned in this case you actually
don't need a prior knowledge and this
algorithm really just are try to give
you a way to explore the top candidates
in a more educated fashion but you bring
it back the question well is it is it
always going to be better than like a
classical turning or other methods in
this case you perform the better but
there's no golden method that works for
all the cases so usually these
algorithms are very case dependent so
you mentioned about how you actually got
dimensionality reduction by modeling the
relative position in space but you
didn't actually mention how you got
around the curse of dimensionality for
the number of targets right so you
talked about training on one target and
that's a simple problem but your state
space also is exponential in the number
of targets so how do you guys deal with
that yes yeah that's a good question I
mentioned briefly uh so we know we
noticed a seeing Laser cat we can play
greedily by just shooting the first
amount
so in this case we only focus on the
first target and uh I know we drink hat
in that fashion that the only focus on
the first target so in this case solve
the problem but of course you can you
can argue that is cheating a little bit
because we are giving you a little bit
prior information hey I'm curious about
under current set settings
how long does your algorithm how long
does it take to converge and did you
face any instability issues yeah
physical instability issues a lot when I
tried a bunch of other algorithms and
then but luckily in this case busy
learning are converged
so like uh technically there's so it
depends on exploration policy if you
have a fixed exploration policy and
you're simply you're trying to learn the
the value associated with that policy
there's convergence guaranteed but if
you are exploring with the policy and
you are trying to estimate the values of
a different policy see the album policy
typically there's no convergence
guarantee and you have a seat check the
results empirically and in this case as
we see in the video like after an hour
and a half
the eye is already performing pretty
well and then in seven hours
pretty much achieves the optimum
performance and it's running at a fifty
fifty fifty states per second so it is
to a large amount of data but then you
know computing wise is in this case it's
not that happy if we don't place
everything onto the screen and we do
parallel computation you can even be
faster Tom wise I as my question was D
if if you ran this algorithm multiple
times do you believe that different
strategies would emerge using different
priors or say you handicapped the AI for
some reason do you think that it would
learn differently on different types of
training yeah so the the strategies will
the parameters will definitely impact
the strategy and for example the piece
count factor if we send to zero your
agent is going to try to only focus on
the immediate reward if we let it to be
big and it's going to take into account
of the more future rewards another
reward itself we also plays a factor
where we are penalizing
the cat for running into the mosque but
if we don't penalize that and the cat is
not going to care about running to the
mosque and it will just try to kill them
so the parameters will influence the
behavior of your agent and even when the
parameters are fixed that could be
multiple optimum policies as long as
they give you the
equal number of values so maybe you can
consider when you play your chess maybe
moving left and moving right we both
give you a checkmate and in that case
moving left and moving right are both
the correct action they are both optimal
policies let's let's thank our speaker
for keeping us safe from space rats
thank you very much